[Music]
mit has this insane abundance of
talented musicians about half the MIT
undergraduate population is taking music
courses every year and there are these
crazily impressive people when the
shutdown started looming in that kind of
final week in March we really started to
realize just how important the immediacy
of being together was and what it meant
to us to be making music in the same
place at the same time so we got them
all microphones and we shipped them off
all over to everybody in the orchestra
and we had actually performed a piece of
brilliant he knows musics called
discrete music and the fall which is
basically a improvisation where
everybody chooses their own tempo and
their own patterns and supposedly it was
just to teach them how to get the right
levels and how to like learn how to
position their mic and stuff like that
but really it was to kind of make a
piece out of this like a collage so I
got these 45 tracks and I put them all
together and suddenly we had made an
orchestra piece together
and I let them know that we're gonna
have the first zoom meeting exactly when
the first rehearsal would have been and
like I just opened up to the program and
all these phases started popping up you
know all these kids that I've been
working with all year and I just got so
happy in a way that I hadn't been really
since the whole thing began you know and
they seemed really happy to see each
other they seemed really happy to just
to connect and I just realized this is
kind of about education and that
stand-up about music that it's also just
about connecting
[Music]
then it was just like well what should
we do next and so we decided that we
would take on Beethoven that so we all
find it hilarious that I walked into
this like trying to do everything but
play Beethoven with this Orchestra you
all hear that but then it turned out
that the second movement of the seventh
symphony was the perfect project in this
situation it had just the right sort of
feeling for the moment because it's sort
of scenario in a weird way but it has
this kind of moments of hope and it goes
up a couple steps and then it stays
there so we'll finish it on the last day
of term but there ain't nothing like the
real thing right so it's not gonna sound
like the Vienna Philharmonic you know
but the other ensembles are doing
similar things that jazz band is working
that way that when ensemble is working
that way it's been great and what's
exciting to me about coming back
together is that we'll have what we've
learned from this experience which is
actually quite a lot of information
about who we all are as musicians what
our skills are I mean I talked to my
colleagues about how we kind of know
more about our students individual
abilities then we did going in because
I'm getting 40 recordings from them a
week
I felt a little bit guilty about the
fact that it had to by necessity
turn into a recording techniques class
that's not what they signed on for they
just wanted to come to our extreme times
a week but is empowering things for them
to them and I realized it helps them in
exactly the ways that they're supposed
to be helped as musicians if you use
this in the right way then you can play
more intuitive you can play more in time
and you can actually hear why it sounds
different so what we've gained from that
technology we can use it and put it back
where it belongs which is as this tool
for togetherness and connection and
empathy and to be able to do that in a
space that's actually designed to make
music it's kind of like and biologists
are doing the best they can to do their
work at home but ultimately when they
get back in the lab they have other
equipment and they have everything
designed in the right way they have the
right temperature control to write clean
rooms then they can really do their work
and so for us we're in this holding
pattern and we're making the best of it
and we're learning things but what we're
really gonna do with that is what
happens when we actually get back
together in a real music space
[Music]
you